Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
September 22nd,
2014 I you doing ow why?
Yeah.
Did you enjoy your weekend?
Well that's good.
I had to wait to respond to,
do you see that?
That's the new me trying to be a little more courteous trying to listen to the
listener.
No to the speaker.
That's how much I interrupt people actually call the other person talking the
listener.
This I call the speaker,
the listener.
That's how I do it.
Now.
Gives a fuck.
Um,
anyways,
I got another Goddamn busy week.
I been writing on this show that I'm trying to get on the fucking air and I'm
not going to tell you really what it is because it doesn't make a difference
cause most of them don't end up making it.
So,
but uh,
I've been in a bubble doing that all fucking day.
And then at night I'm trying to go out and write some new jokes cause I got some
shows coming up.
Um,
I'm going to be in San Francisco.
We just added another,
the show at the Davies arena whenever the fuck it's called.
And uh,
so I appreciate everybody in San Francisco.
I plan on kicking the shit out of you and giving you your money's worth.
So I've been going out like every night here in Los Angeles,
trying to get up on stage somewhere somehow somewhere.
And uh,
I've been writing during the day.
I got a fucking job.
Everybody,
you know,
I got a little pass code key.
I come in,
say hello to the fucking person at the desk.
How are you?
And I fucking do the little swipey thing and I go in there,
pop,
pop.
Right?
And I fucking go in there and I try to come up with some funny shit to add to
the other funny shit that other people are writing.
Um,
no,
Jeez.
It's actually been a lot of fun to be honest with you.
And uh,
I'm learning,
I'm learning to ride.
I'm learning how a script comes together,
which I never knew how to do it because I was too scattered brain and a,
for the most part in life.
I'm a fucking quit.
I really am.
I just,
when I go do something,
if it's easy and it's fun,
I keep doing it.
If there's a little bit of work to it,
that brutal combination is if there's a little bit of work and I don't like it,
I'm done.
And a that would explain my,
my high school transcripts,
I did horrible fucking horrible in high school.
Like I don't know how,
like if that was a PGA tournament,
I would not have made the cut.
Um,
okay.
I think freshman year I might've made the cut,
but sophomore,
no junior known.
Especially in senior year it was,
it was over.
It was fucking over.
You know what,
you know what my fucking high school performance was like basically the Broncos
in last year's super bowl.
All right.
I walked up to the line of scrimmage and I'm like,
I'm going to be a lawyer.
I'm going to Notre Dame.
That's what I'm doing freshman year.
Right.
It comes,
you know,
first play from scrimmage,
everybody yelling and it fucking went right up over my head for a safety.
I never got the rhythm back.
I know there was no rhythm,
there was nothing.
I did really well.
I did really well right up to eighth grade that really,
really well.
But I did great.
I gradually tapered off my,
like my academic career from first grade to 12th grade was like,
like an athlete's career.
You know,
I had young,
fresh legs and everything was going great.
I was bouncing up after he hits and tackles and all that shit.
A cruise through first,
second and third grade and I got my first c I think in fourth grade
and in fifth grade I had to quit my baseball team cause I got a d in math.
Then sixth grade I came back strong contract year,
right.
Going into seventh grade,
seventh grade I did decent.
Eighth Grade I did decent,
didn't quite live up to the big contract they gave me.
After that stunning sixth grade year and then ninth grade or I dunno,
I blew up,
my Achilles came back from injury and the sophomore dredges to just shit the
bed.
It was over.
It was over by senior year,
I was wearing my Joe Nemeth Rams Jersey,
academically speaking,
and it was fucking over and that's the way it was back in 1987.
Um,
so anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast site and he knew,
listens listeners out there,
how are you welcome to people who listen to this around the world,
world,
world.
Um,
what the fuck happened in Scotland?
You know,
you would have,
I thought that they were going to break away.
I thought they had had enough.
You know what I should do as I shouldn't read up on it at all.
I should just start talking about it.
You know,
that's my God given right as a fucking American rights Scotland.
Um,
independence.
Let's see what happened when the folks who are fucking court,
the podcast,
you're fucking scared.
Where include,
um,
polls were pretty bad.
It says Scotland faces challenge of putting reference referendum behind them.
Oh yeah.
He just started everybody up.
This is probably even more fights in the bus
again to a Scottish accent.
The only reason why I could say what I already said was cause it was said to me,
other than that it can't do it.
I'm like a really bad person here.
You know what I mean?
Like if I,
if those like a really bad impression is all they do is the shit that people say
in the movies.
Like I'll be back.
They just do that.
But you know,
the really great ones like Jay Moore can actually do a Arnold Schwarzenegger in
therapy talking about having a child out of wedlock,
you know?
Um,
anyways,
well I'm all over the fucking place.
The pros and cons of Scottish independence as if your life wasn't boring enough.
Let's talk about this shit.
I think it's a good move that they didn't,
uh,
that they didn't break away.
Right.
Okay.
The Scotland have an army or a navy.
Go fuck yourselves.
All right.
I'm sorry that I don't know this shit.
Okay.
Why don't you fucking invade somebody every once in a while and maybe,
maybe I'll know about your team's over there.
All right.
The effort.
No.
Referendum ends one debate,
but sparks a new question about the devolution of power to Scotland.
I hope I said that right.
Scotland has rejected independence falling way.
Historically high turnout at yesterday's referendum,
chief accounting officer and Mary pick a Deli,
whatever the fuck her name is officially announced that no side one by 55%
oh the no side
and the worst that the no side one by 55% to 45% no normal person was allowed to
count the votes.
So everyone has to take that as fact.
Uh,
the clock and my shy,
shy Shire Council was the first local authority to announce its results at
around 1:30 AM or gives a fuck.
You at Union is celebrated victories.
Blahblahblahblahblah nationalists,
one done d by pretty blah,
blah,
blah.
Well,
what the fuck?
Why did he wait a minute.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
Whoa.
Okay.
When did Scotland become part of the UK?
The acts of union between Scotland and England were pass the 1706 taken effect.
Didn't they get taken over?
I don't know.
Something happened there.
And next thing you know,
Mel Gibson was in dress.
That's all I know.
He was in a scared,
um,
yeah.
Why are you going to work?
You know,
I don't,
you know something,
I don't know anything about it.
I don't know anything about it,
but I bet there was a bunch of old Scottish people who didn't want to upset.
You know,
they were going to take the evil that they knew rather than the unknown evil,
you know,
what are they doing tax in the Shit Outta you making you do the shit jobs?
Is that what it is?
What would have happened to England if,
Scott,
can you guys answer me these fucking questions cause I'm not going to read up on
it.
What would it happen to?
The power of England.
Okay.
You know,
which I don't even know what it's based on at this point because they don't own
shit anymore.
Do they?
What do they,
oh,
they got like the Canary Islands in Northern Ireland and Scotland and Wales.
Right.
Falkland Islands.
Didn't they lose that?
Something happened over there like 30 fucking years ago and all of a sudden the
planes would take an off straight,
straight up in the air.
I remember that
way back in the day.
Nancy Reagan.
Ronald Reagan.
Yeah.
Uh,
Margaret Thatcher.
I don't fucking know.
I don't know what happened.
I can't believe how little I even know about it.
I can even,
I,
I don't know anything about it.
I'm going to shut up then.
Well,
congratulations to people of Scotland,
uh,
who didn't want to leave.
And I feel bad for those who did and I really wish I could have talked about it
a little more intelligently.
But,
uh,
you know,
every once in a while you just,
you just,
you know,
you think the water is like two inches deep and next thing you know,
you're in over your head.
That's what happened to me.
Oh,
Jj is,
that might've been the worst discussion of anything political ever.
That was even bad for me.
That was a fucking embarrassment.
Well,
I'll tell you right now,
it far,
that last conversation was indicative of what this podcast is going to be.
I could tell you right now,
I don't think he's going to get it done this week.
Okay.
Uh,
if you take the chicken to have a good podcast and the national park casting
league with that type of performance.
Ah Man,
man,
man.
What,
what did I say about his preparation?
Ooh,
I could change.
Um,
I didn't watch any of that.
You guys want you in the pregame analysis?
You know what I was,
I,
I have a rental car.
Of course.
Still a rental car.
I haven't seen my fucking truck in like months because the people fixing the
downstairs,
they've got to walk to my garage and I don't want to get it scratched.
I want to leave it out on the street.
So I got it in storage.
It started up once a week.
That's my life.
Okay.
So anyways,
I've been driving this fucking car.
I got this new one and I suck with technology.
I can't figure out how to turn the radio on two auxiliary so I can listen to my
fucking show tunes there as I drive down the street.
Right.
Roll out the barrel.
That's the kind of music I listen to when I drive.
You know,
I listened to funny girl.
Yeah.
Oh Glove Houma.
When the something something and there's something,
right.
I don't know any fucking show tunes.
Wait a minute.
To dream the impossible dream to dress like a fucking kitty cat
to descend on a glowing moon.
Well a crowd of old hey eggs and some young homosexuals cry in the crowd.
Um,
anyways.
Sorry.
All right.
What the fuck am I talking about here?
There was something I wanted to talk about before I started singing show tunes.
Oh yeah.
I was driving down the fucking street and the car and I can't figure out how to
listen to my God damn songs.
So I've just been listening to sports talk radio cause I don't want to listen to
real news.
It's too fucking depressing.
I don't want to listen to them.
Try and sell me on the idea that we just have to go into Syria.
Yeah.
Now we just got it.
Doe It.
It's our job to go over there and tell these people,
well Yay.
Yay.
Hey,
that's about enough for
is we suck their natural resources out of the fucking ground and bomb the living
shit out of innocent people standing around.
You know,
I don't want to listen to them sell me in another one of those.
Yeah.
Well as it's an initial freedom,
the way they are [inaudible] whether somebody needs to be done.
I thought,
hey pal that I,
well I don't give a fuck.
I don't care anymore.
All right.
Oh and I would vote.
I would vote if you actually fucking countered them.
Um,
and if I wasn't lazy as Shit,
I got a big pamphlet today.
There was telling me all about the local officials and I just took one look at
that.
Does it mean it's written on recycled paper?
It's overcast paper.
That's what it looks like.
Overcast skies,
except there's typing on it.
They do it on purpose.
Who the fuck is going to read that?
MMM.
So anyways,
I was driving down the street Lulu,
Lulu Dude,
and I'm listening to a that Mike and Mike in the morning and like I've been,
I've been really hard on these fucking pregame postgame sports talk guys.
I actually now have empathy for them.
I understand what they're doing.
There's just too much time.
There's too much air time between games.
And they just have to talk everything to death.
And this week I swear to God,
yeah,
my goal luck of the Mike and Mike Show,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
They read a letter and a,
it was somebody who's basically,
he was tight.
He was respectfully tired of listening to the Adrian Peterson Story,
the ray rice story and all of that shit.
And it was just like,
can we just get back to talking about football?
Signed a tired football fan.
And I swear to God this,
I'm paraphrasing,
but this is kind of what gold said.
He goes,
you know what I want to do?
I want to,
I want to right now,
I don't want to talk to the players.
I don't want to talk to y'all.
I don't want to talk to the media.
I want to talk to you.
The Fan.
They know when I'm on Mike,
Mike,
this is something that I want to get out there.
Is,
is this game your safe haven?
Yeah.
Is it your safe haven?
Like on Sunday when you sit down in your chair,
okay.
Eh,
and,
and you,
you,
you take out your,
your,
your favorite beverage.
Is that your safe haven is the national football,
he kept saying,
is that your safe haven?
What the fuck does that mean?
How simplistic and fucking stupid do they think the average football fan is?
Was I supposed to be driving in my car on,
I've heard of safety.
What?
I watched football.
What the fuck is he talking about?
I got to tell you something.
This is really immature.
Me.
I hate when overweight people bring up food.
I don't what it is,
but I swear to God you can already hear them salivating.
I never had an issue with the word beverage until I heard Mike Golic said,
you need to take out your favorite beverage.
I just heard the fucking ice hitting the inside of the glass and I swear to God
I wanted to drive into a fucking pole.
I had to shut it off like three times,
but I was like,
no,
this is good for the podcast.
You got to listen to it.
And uh,
he just,
is it,
is it your safe haven?
I mean just absolutely out of shit to talk about.
I mean,
I didn't know what,
what the,
what the fuck does that?
I didn't listen to it long enough to somebody actually call in
a safe fucking haven.
You know what?
I'm going to look that up right now and I want to see examples of safe havens.
I know exactly what they are.
It's like captains in the middle of a fucking storm trying to find a port so
they don't get smashed on rocks.
Yeah.
Either that or some fat fucking his pajamas with some potato skins watching
football.
Yeah.
Just,
let's just,
let's just fucking devalue safe haven.
I'm looking it up right now.
Below was a movie.
There's a film.
It's a county.
How about a fucking definition?
Well,
Bill,
why don't you search for that and stop yelling at a screen.
All right.
Definition.
Safe Haven.
A place of refuge or security.
Temporary refuge given to a person.
Persecuted person or group.
So is he trying to say that were persecuted by them saying,
talking about the same shit day after fucking day after day.
Yeah.
Is it your safe haven?
Okay.
And officially protected place in an area of military activity or any safe or
peaceful place in a dangerous area.
All right.
Amanda magnets to say that he overstepped the bounds of the definition of that
word to apply it to sitting there fucking eating pizza and drinking booze.
Okay.
You know,
I don't fucking know.
Anyways.
Um,
and I'm sitting there going like,
how fucking dumb does this guy think the average football fan is?
And then I watched the Fsu gang and I am a huge fan
okay.
Of Florida state.
I've always loved the Seminoles.
I want to go to a game I had went to,
I did a show down there like a year and a half ago,
but I got to tell you something.
I watched this fucking game and in the first drive alone,
they played that fucking,
what do you call the Tomahawk chance song?
They must have played it like seven times.
Duh.
Right.
And the fucking crowd is going on
fucking arms.
I get it.
Everybody's got their little yeah.
Thing that they do,
you know,
and uh,
I,
you know,
whatever,
you just kind of fucking and mocking a,
a group of people that were victims of genocide.
How many,
who's to say,
I mean,
if the Nazis,
you know,
if they won World War Two,
what will they not have had dev version of the Tomahawk Chop with?
Oh,
a Jewish people.
Yeah.
What would they be doing?
What is,
what if you were doing,
if the Nazis won and then they fucking named their team offensive names about
Jewish people,
what would the Tomahawk Chop?
What would it be?
Okay.
Oh,
eva or whatever the fuck you was a Yada,
Yada,
and I was,
fuck you.
I'm sorry.
What do you want from me?
I'm tired.
Right?
They would all have like fucking,
they'd be dressed like just Siddiq Jews or something like that,
but cartoonish version.
It's like one of them would come out riding a fucking horse with a goddamn
briefcase,
some shit,
and he'd fucking go to slam it down on the 50 yard line for getting it was
handcuffed to his wrist and he turned his head to a lawn dart.
Something like that.
Right?
Oh,
eva.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We'll
the Berlin woody Allen's
Berlin.
Woody's.
I'm sorry,
what do you want from me anyways?
Anyway,
so what the fuck.
So I,
and then what was worse was they kept cutting to the crowd and you know,
I talked to fire her or nothing.
You know,
I always heard that the checks at Fsu a fucking,
I heard they will hot dude.
All I saw,
it looked like,
you know,
there was a hurricane and everybody,
I dunno.
Well they,
they look for a safe haven in fucking Walmart and they just opened the door and
all these fucking zombies came.
I was just a bunch of people standing there mindlessly moving their fucking,
I'm
like,
I'm telling you like 1520 times a half,
40 times in a fucking gang,
just sitting there doing that shit.
And I just,
okay.
You don't want to do right now.
I don't want to talk to the players.
Yeah.
I don't want to talk to me.
I want to talk to the fans.
I want to talk to the fans in that fucking stadium.
Like what?
What is going through your fucking head?
The 30th,
the 35th fucking time you're doing that.
At any point,
do you sit there and start to question whether you're an individual anymore?
What kind of a fucking person you do if you're,
I don't know.
I never been to the game.
Do you,
do you take a few of them off?
Okay.
Right.
Well,
you know,
what am I going to do it this time?
Just,
just so I can keep a piece of me,
right.
I don't know.
Don't listen to me.
I am completely,
I am antisocial,
like beyond belief.
The stuff that actually makes me mad.
It's weird.
I like can't stand people and I also liked them.
I can't stand him to the point.
I don't want to be around them.
But when I see them doing shit that I feel they're above,
um,
it makes me sad for him.
Like,
I was sad for some of those people when I looked at him like,
what are you dope?
Come on.
You know,
I don't want to use that hacky term.
You're better than that.
I hate when people say that shit.
It's like,
you know what?
You're better.
You're better than you.
Better than that.
All right.
Don't try your fucking first grade psychology on me.
Oh baby.
I am better than that.
Oh,
I guess I agree with you.
Now.
Give me a fucking break.
Um,
it's like when you see people waiting out for a fucking phone.
Yeah.
Like those fucking losers.
I can't,
it,
you're into the,
I get it that you're into it.
All right.
Whatever the fuck I'm into.
Whatever.
I like playing drums.
Let's say they came out with the greatest fucking drum kit and you could have a
fucking hat.
And I wanted it worse than I,
and I wanted anything in my life like the way those fucking kids,
like the God damn iPhone.
This,
I'm not sleeping out on a sidewalk for it.
Yeah.
When a week later I could just walk in like a fucking human being.
Go.
Yeah.
Good.
Let me get one of those.
Thank you.
Box it up there,
rusty.
Right?
The first one.
This one,
it has the phone.
Yeah.
You know,
I asked this week on Twitter,
I asked what,
what Roku was.
Somebody gave me a Roku.
Right.
I had no idea what I opened it.
And uh,
I had no idea what it was.
Yeah.
And um,
you know what's funny,
I so didn't even know what it was.
I don't even like read.
Yeah.
I noticed that about myself.
Like it's said Roku right on the box.
Okay.
But I was just looking at the picture of it and I was reading the fine print or
immediately I didn't know what the fuck it was.
So I did a live podcast with Al Madrigal and uh,
I was trying to describe what it was,
cause I didn't know what it was in Neil Brennan.
I gotta give him props,
actually called it.
He said,
is it a Roku?
And I think I said no.
Okay.
Anyways,
I tried looking it up on the Internet and I,
and the description of it,
I'd still didn't understand what it was.
So like an asshole.
I ask on my Twitter,
I go,
hey,
this isn't any,
I just said,
you know what's a Roku
and you can't believe this shit.
I understand like the funny answers that people gave me,
but there was a lot of people giving me fucking shit like I was a moron or
something.
I don't get that shit talking with technology where just because you go out and
you buy the latest thing,
like that somehow makes you smarter than me now.
Okay.
I could see if you invented it.
It's like the person who invented Roku said I was a fucking moron.
I mean I got to take that one on the chin,
but if you're just another breathing moron
like me walking around the fucking best buy and you walk in and you buy a Roku,
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't get the fucking shit talk.
That's all I'm saying.
All these nerds,
all of a sudden action like quarterbacks in the NFL getting in my fucking face
on Twitter.
Jesus.
I feel like I'm bitching a lot this week.
Let's,
let's do a little,
uh,
let's do a little advertisement.
Let's do a little advertisement here.
Um,
all right.
All right.
What the fuck is it?
A dollar shave club.
Everybody.
Is there anything worse than buying razors?
You got to remember that you need them in the first place.
You got to sit in traffic to go to the store.
You've got to find that locked plaque.
Uh,
that locked plastic fortress.
They keep them in.
That's so ridiculous that you got to find somebody with a key,
right?
Find the one dude,
he's got the key and he's in the back texting his girlfriend or he's outside
smoking a joint.
After all that,
it's going to set you back like 25 bucks.
Do you really need to deal with that anymore?
You don't never do it again.
Just joined dollar Shave Club for a few bucks a month.
Dollar Shave Club delivers you great raises right to your door.
Dollar Shave club.com is so,
so much smarter than going to the store.
They're plan starts at just three bucks a month.
Signing up takes only two minutes than sit back and let the blades arrive like
clockwork.
You can shave with a fresh blade every week,
no membership fee,
no commitment,
and they have a money back guarantee.
You have nothing to lose by trying them out.
Stop trudging to the store for overprice razors.
Join the dollar shave club.com/burr revolution.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr B u.
R.
All right,
draft kings,
everybody.
Dude,
I called it.
I said these guys were going to be huge.
They're actually advertising during football games.
They're,
they're,
they're doing so well at this point.
All right.
Draft kings,
everybody.
Fantasy football's back and draft kings.com isn't messing around.
Draft kings.com is America's favorite one week fantasy football site where you
could win enormous cash prizes every week.
You've already researched the place for your season long fantasy team.
Turn that knowledge into instantCash@dollarshaveclub.com last year,
one player turned 11 bucks into four grand in one weekend,
another 100 grand his first time playing ever.
And another player won a million bucks in one day.
Just playing fantasy football.
What are you waiting for?
Keep your season long league where it is,
but also play one week fantasy,
a draft king.com to win huge cash this week.
Hurry up,
get free entry into the millionaire maker event where first place takes home 1
million bucks.
Head over to draft kings.com now and enter the Promo Code d thanks to um,
you spelt regularly.
D F e n s e to play free to become a millionaire.
draftkings.com bigger events,
bigger winnings,
bigger millionaires.
Enter defense for entry
now@draftkingsdotcomdraftkingsdotcomthatisdraftkings.com.
All right,
uh,
one more here.
Legal Zoom,
everybody.
boom,
boom.
Oh legal zoom,
zoom,
and he don't boom.
Bodo we do a,
when you're planning for your future,
you do financial planning,
you get insurance.
But to get real peace of mind,
you've got to make sure your family and finances are legally protected.
So where do you turn for legal help?
You can trust legal zoom.com for over 13 years they've been helping Americans
get personalized wills,
powers of attorneys,
and living trust.
Legal Zoom also helps file LLCs,
s corporations and more to protect you against personal liability.
The company was started by some of the best legal minds in the country and they
make it painless for you to get the legal protection you need.
Have questions.
You can always reach out to someone at legal zoom and they'll help you.
They'll help talk you through the process.
You can get legal help through independent attorneys and self help services at
your discretion,
but they are not a law firm for a special,
for special savings,
be sure to enter my code,
B U R R in the referral box at checkout.
Go to legalzoom.com Promo Code [inaudible] today to protect your business and
take control of your family's future.
All right,
with that,
let's get back to the,
uh,
to the
cast here.
Um,
anyways,
what else did I do this week?
I watched a bunch of football.
I got to tell you.
Um,
I've got to tell you,
I'd be like gotta be a little concerned with what I saw up there and stock
sparrow with the New England patriots.
Um,
I don't know.
You don't,
what the Patriots have been doing forever is we,
we get rid of guys,
we get rid of veterans and the final third of their career when they want the
big bucks,
we kind of let them go.
Thai law lawyer Malloy a fucking defensive tackle we sent to the Raiders.
I mean there's been so many of them.
Latest one Logan Mankins Senate to a Tampa Bay or whatever.
And um,
I don't think that's working for us because you get a great veteran and then
that dude leaves and then you have a hole in that position for like three years
waiting for somebody to get up to speed.
And by the time that guy figures out how to play the position,
somebody else gets let go.
And now we've got a problem over there.
I mean,
I guess you're always going to have a fucking problem.
But,
um,
I don't know.
I see a slowly starting to slide.
I mean,
the way we let the Raiders hang around that long and they should have won the
fucking game.
They didn't shoot the other beat the Raiders if they didn't shoot themselves in
the foot.
I just don't understand why the Raiders,
they just,
I dunno.
It's like they knew how to win games and for the last 30 years they stopped all
went out.
The fucking,
I dunno.
I think it's Karma.
It's a Karma thing.
It has to do with their fans and how they disgraced being a football fan by
going there dressed up like spongebob squarepants but you have on brass
knuckles.
I just don't understand that.
I don't understand why you have to take your dignity and throw it out the
fucking window.
Or am I talking about all rate of fans I'm talking to,
you know,
with fans of talking about.
All right.
So thank God it was a home game so they didn't have to keep talking about the
black hole,
you know,
you know those,
you know those places to black hole,
the dog pound,
the entire Seattle Seahawks stadium actually watched it.
What a fucking game that was,
man.
Um,
Seattle,
a Broncos game,
fucking awesome game.
But at one point they cut to the crowd and some guy had this fucking lime green
Sam that you sign that just said loud,
like he went out and made that or something.
It's just the dumbest thing.
I have to commend them.
I,
I mean I fast forward through a lot of it cause I,
you know,
I was out living a life when I came back and I watched the tape,
my tape of the,
uh,
the game and uh,
they didn't bring it up that much,
which thank God they didn't enough already with the stupid 12th man and all of
that shit.
Um,
anyways,
but the game was fucking awesome.
And,
um,
I thought Seattle,
I thought it was done.
And uh,
what was it,
20 to five,
17 to five or something like that.
I think it was like 21,
five.
I don't even know.
Fucking Broncos came back in.
Our Peyton throws a big pic and then comes back with the,
I don't know,
I don't get why on that final drive,
whenever it's every fucking drive is that the prevent defense,
they always go down the field and score or they always,
they always drive down.
At the very least they're going to get in the red zone.
That whole bullshit of like,
you know,
we'll uh,
take away the sidelines and we'll give them the middle of the field and somehow
this just magically not supposed to be enough time left on the clock and they
fucking always is like 90% of the time.
But it actually seemed like a Seattle was playing defense set.
You blowing your nose in that Nia.
Yeah,
she's got the allergies.
Um,
cute little nose.
She makes all that noise.
Um,
anyways,
it was a great fucking game and I was happy that uh,
you know,
both teams played well and there wasn't any fucking incidents of screaming,
yelling or any of that type of shit.
Um,
the day started off bad with them talking about the,
uh,
the Goddamn Paul Tag.
You'll boot boo or fucking Pete Rozelle,
whatever the fucking new guy's name is.
I don't even know what his name is,
Doug Fairbanks.
We're going to,
wouldn't go with that.
Gary Greenberg.
The fuck is his name.
You'd think it.
Yeah.
That's how much I don't watch it.
I put it on it.
Then there's time Jackson and,
and uh,
Keenan Ivory Wayans what are the fuck Keyshawn Johnson,
right.
And I'm like,
oh,
I like those guys.
Those guys used to play,
they know the fucking game and then,
you know,
they got the big pasty doughy boy,
looks like he's in one of those big fucking sitcoms,
right?
Third Rock from the sun where they lived with big foot and alf made like a
cameo.
Whenever the hell is one of those furry fucking shows.
Right.
He looks like the dad on one of those shows,
doesn't me.
And um,
that gave you as a check,
you'd be like a milk maid,
you know,
but he only be like a six.
So anyways,
he goes up there and he's like,
no,
I did go right.
Laws Dot.
Uh,
[inaudible] I,
you go right and you're gonna die tomorrow.
We're going to do every day to make sure we get it right.
Get it right.
He's in then sports speak,
and then they cut back to the players and the players,
you know are now fucking wherein Anderson little suits and they're fucking,
then they start talking,
go ahead,
go.
You know the Paul g,
uh,
deputy thing.
It was shea and what are they going to do in the future?
All my God.
Okay.
Is it wrong to say who gives a fuck at this point?
The guy's not going to quit his goddamn job.
You're not going to kick him out.
All right?
He gets it next time.
A player slugs,
his wife,
fiance,
or just some random woman walking down the street in,
in the face,
they're going to show the whole video the first day and they will suspend the
person indefinitely.
Okay.
You know,
it's great to halfway through when I was listening to that sports talk radio
show,
they had al Michaels calling who does not speak in sports speak because uh,
you know,
he's found his own voice.
He's a legend.
So he called up and he was just saying how the whole league got tarred and
feathered because of a couple of guys.
And he actually claimed that the spousal abuse rate in the NFL not only is less
than general society,
but way less so.
What was all the screaming and yelling about?
I don't fucking get it all that fuck.
They have a real problem.
They actually looked like they doing a little better doing better than the
plumber's contract is standup comedians and everybody else walking around
outside that stadium,
the new drinking game.
Listen to Mike and Mike in the morning and every time Mike goal that goes,
Eh,
in between points you got to take a shot.
I swear to God you're going to have your stomach pumped 45 minutes into it.
They came out in the first quarter and I mean they were all over up.
Um,
okay.
Is there anything else to talk about here?
And I talked about Roku.
I talked about the games that I watched.
Um,
oh,
double bass drumming by the way.
I'm trying to,
you know,
I made fun of,
I didn't make fun of it.
I just said,
you know,
it's just so fucking,
after a while
that I,
I,
you know,
I don't hear a groove anymore and some double bass drum is called,
uh,
told me,
update the fucking twittered me.
And they were like,
Eh,
kind of bummed me out.
You said you didn't like the blast beats and shit like that.
I don't mean I don't like them.
I just,
you know,
my,
I don't know,
I just don't gravitate towards a already have that level of rage in me.
I don't need a soundtrack to it.
Like I need to go the other way.
I need to listen to the sounds of waterfalls,
you know?
Um,
so anyways,
okay,
I want to do another one of those goddamn comedy jam and the sign that I picked
out add a little bit of double basin.
So I've been trying to get,
you know,
I pulled up the double pedal from the fucking back of the closet and,
um,
I gotta tell you man,
it fucking,
it's,
it's hard as Shit I've always respected.
That's why I bought it.
Like I bought a double pedal like 12 years ago when my obsession with John
Bonham got to the point that all I was doing was listening to led Zeppelin and I
wasn't developing at all any creative ideas,
nothing playing drums.
So it's like,
why don't I get outside of this and get a double pedal?
And I fucked around with it on and off and I just never had the discipline to
stay with it.
So I've been trying to stay with it the last couple of weeks and I'm,
I'm fucking horrible.
I'm horrible.
I mean,
I'm talking like 85 90 beats per minute before it starts sounding like I'm
galloping rather than a nice smooth sound.
So,
uh,
I got,
I always had a ton of respect.
Um,
oh,
you know what's funny,
I actually opened for a,
went down and did a guest spot in front of Dean del Ray.
At the Improv this week.
And,
uh,
he used to sing in a band,
so he knows all these musicians.
And one of the guys that came down out to the show was the drummer from slayer.
Dave Lombardo,
I got to talk to him for a couple seconds.
Speaking of,
you know,
legendary drummer,
double bass drum mic,
um,
was a great fucking guy.
And um,
I don't know.
It's one of the great things about living out here in la.
He's like,
you'll fucking move somewhere and that guy will be a next door neighbor.
Okay.
That there's just people that are in show business out here.
It's fucking hilarious.
Do you know,
I went to a Superbowl party one time and I met somebody and they would just
like,
yeah,
okay.
Hey.
They started talking to him and I found out his,
his grandfather played the guy that was in the bed with the severed horse head
in godfather one.
How fucking cool is that?
Okay.
It's like your grandfather did that.
Yeah.
Do you know he had no idea how big the movie was going to be.
They put a fake head Nordea.
He's screaming,
yelled,
what did your grandfather do?
They worked at Eva's.
Um,
all right,
let's move on.
Okay,
let's get to the lettuce for this week.
The fucking law.
A bill stop saying,
sorry,
dare Billy red face.
I,
I have been listening to your podcast for about a year and are hilarious
and I have noticed these fellas spelling with like letters not,
and he just the letter n and I have noticed you say something outrageous and
funny.
Then say sorry.
You're not responsible.
You can say whatever the fuck you want to ends.
And one without apologizing.
Both of those words spelled wrong.
Keep that shit up.
You funny bastard.
Thanks for the podcast and go fuck yourself.
Um,
no,
I'm gonna keep saying sorry if I fucking do a joke then think it's a little
corny or a,
he went a little too long with it.
I apologize.
I'm trying to have respect for you,
but I appreciate the fact that you enjoy the podcast.
Please keep listening.
All right.
American who grew up in Singapore.
Oh,
I love it last week than any of you guys have the nerve to go.
Look at that caning video.
Holy Shit yet.
Okay.
That's not something you don't look at it cause you won't ever forget it.
Um,
hey Billy.
I have,
I have lived,
so this is an American who grew up in Singapore.
I've lived in Singapore for five years,
or I lived in Singapore for five years.
In the late eighties through the early nineties I was a kid,
but I remember they had public commercials for Caney somewhere like the semi
funny Dui commercials we have in California and somewhere like short film
versions of hot of hostels.
Oh,
of hostile.
Oh wasn't that a horror movie?
They even had billboards and bus signs that depicted offenses that would warn
it.
Warrant caning complete with soar asked cartoon characters.
Caning was even a thing and there's soap operas and TV shows.
The message was clear.
You fuck around and you're going to get caned.
The Michael Fay thing happened when I was 11 this is fascinating,
but I remember feeling no sympathy for the guy.
I always thought he gave the US a bad name for a being a dumb ass in a foreign
country.
And B,
not owning up to his own bullshit.
I have no love for Singapore,
but I think their nation points out a sad fact.
The only way you can have a society with less than one murder a year,
no drug offenders with a pristine subway.
And then he writes in parentheses,
you could literally eat ice cream off the floor is by hanging felons and beating
the shit out of everyone.
I love you.
Oh my God.
Jesus Christ.
Is that true?
Can you imagine if they had caning in this country?
How many,
how many of us would deserve a caning?
How fucking crash you can act and that and that before you get on your fucking
high horse.
Anybody listened to this and Canada,
England and Australia and all the other God damn places.
Okay,
you'd all take a couple of fucking,
you take nice couple of fucking whack.
She yourself.
You know,
I went to slap my leg and even then I pulled it cause I do pull,
pulled the punch because I didn't want to fucking hurt myself.
MMM.
Yeah,
I guess so if you hang felons that really cuts out the whole a recidivism,
you know?
No,
no repeat offenders in Singapore
and they beat it.
Let me tell you something.
They beat the shit out of you.
This guy took like six of them.
Like they,
there's some times like I heard punishments of up to 12 and some people were
saying like other parts of the world,
you get like 96 lashings.
I mean,
you just passed out.
I gotta tell you it is inhumane as it is.
Like let's just say I got,
I,
you know,
I don't want to put this fucking id in anybody's head.
I am Jesus Christ.
How many fights?
I mean,
that would be it.
I wouldn't,
I would,
I dunno what I would do.
You know what I would do?
I would do,
I would work in the back of a Coldstone creamery.
If I ever took 96 lashings,
that would be it.
That'd be end of my dreams.
All of that would be a broken man.
Like,
all right dude,
I get it.
You're running shit.
Fuck this.
I'm going in the back here.
I'm going to fucking stir up some ice cream.
I'll come out when I got to sing the hi Ho.
Hi Ho.
Well make an ice cream.
We go whatever fucking song I got to sing.
I'm wearing the uniform.
You know.
Everybody likes to think that there'd be that guy going,
you know,
after they give me a 96 lashes and just sitting there,
and they come up to you and they say some and then you'd go fuck you and you
spit in their face.
I think that just happens in the movies.
Even if you think in fuck you,
you're not going to say it again.
What is the point of taking more lashes?
At least like,
all right,
I'm going to get this motherfucker later.
Okay.
Absolutely sir.
You are the boss.
I got my mind right gum.
I'm like shaking a Bush,
walking it off,
boss,
walking it off.
All right,
bad luck dear Mr. Burn,
what to do when everything goes south for an extended period of time.
So I am a 32 year old with quite a good track record,
former semi pro hockey player,
three university degrees in rather good shape and overall not that ugly and he
got a sense of humor.
You're crushing it.
One sentence in,
I love this guy.
Two sentences is however,
I have had no luck with girls jobs.
Our health.
In the past 10 years,
I have had almost every Dezeen disease known to man.
Okay.
There is a little bit padding in that story.
I have unbelievably bad luck with jobs always.
When I get my dream job,
something from outside comes and stops me getting there.
This has happened three times now and the last one was one of the classics.
The company went to hiring to a hiring and let 25% of the workforce go and
girls,
well,
I could get some,
but I just have no interactions with girls.
With personalities.
I would like,
uh,
they are out there,
but if I meet them,
it does not go anywhere.
I love sports and now I have been unable to train for a year and a half due to a
disease,
heart problems plus virus.
Uh,
I am unable to do work.
So there is that.
Even if I would like to get a job,
there was none available.
And I am a cunt working in fa in the finance industry.
I am sure I am not the only one to be in this situation.
So my question for you is how do you believe in your future?
If everything's been shit so far,
please go for an account yourself.
Yours sincerely.
A ps.
English is not my first language,
so please excuse me.
Well,
that was pretty impressive.
Um,
all right,
so how do you continue?
Uh,
okay.
Thinking positively.
Um,
it's a choice.
You just have to decide to do it.
I mean,
what else are you gonna do?
Are you going to let it win?
He can't let it win.
And everybody who's been successful always has,
you know,
they have all this stories.
Okay.
When they sit around telling stories about,
you know,
after they've been successful,
all they talk about is the shit that they fucking went through,
which is most of panel.
If you look,
if you watch a late night talk show of a comic goes on,
he's not going to talk about the time he killed.
He's going to talk about the time he bombed the time of buddy lost his agent at
the time,
his fucking TV show get cancelled.
All the pain of that and all that.
Cause you know,
it's funny,
but the big thing is,
is when you're sitting there watching it go on,
this person went through all of this shit.
So,
uh,
I feel bad that you're going through all this,
especially the health part.
MMM.
I Dunno what kind of virus she had,
but I mean,
not like if you told me I fucking know anything,
I was still like,
I'm a doctor obviously,
so.
MMM.
What I would do if I was you was,
I would,
I would focus on what you can control.
You can't work out,
but there's nothing stopping you from eating perfectly.
Um,
how about something low impact like yoga,
like I don't ever see where light stretching and eating is perfectly as you
possibly can,
would ever be a detriment to your health.
So that would be a step in the positive direction.
And um,
okay.
As far as like your bad luck with women to fuck that dude.
Fuck that.
There's no such thing.
You just keep,
you just keep getting back.
What,
what,
what is the worst?
They're gonna say no.
Who gives a fuck?
They laugh at Shit.
You're already laughing at yourself.
All right?
You just become undeniable.
You become unstoppable.
It's just not going to beat you.
All right.
Who knows?
Who knows how long you're going to be here?
Who knows how long I'm going to be here.
But like every issue,
you're fucking living your life day to day.
You can't let it beat you.
That's basically it.
And you make that fucking choice.
Now get out there the second half,
crushed some ash,
do some yoga and eat some goddamn beats.
Um,
yeah,
that's what I would say.
I would just fucking refuse to let this thing,
you know,
just do that that fucking day,
day to day thing,
you might win,
but not today.
All right,
I'm tougher than you today.
Go Fuck yourself and I'm gonna join this day.
There you golf.
I would do that.
And uh,
I dunno,
I,
in the end,
if you're going to be around women don't have an angry energy like me that is
like raid to women.
Don't do that.
All right?
You attract psychos and uh,
it's just,
it's just not a good situation.
So anyways.
All right.
A hundred days without booze.
Hey,
bill,
ball sack,
pill ball,
Saginaw,
parentheses.
I Dunno,
I tried.
All right.
Quickly to the point,
I'm doing a hundred days clean.
I love it.
Inspired by your podcast a while back,
I like the whole deadline thing.
Knowing there's only x more days to go and stuff.
Makes it easier,
makes it easier to do it.
I feel better.
I'm not pissed off as much.
I'm not,
I'm getting a handle on my money.
This is all good things,
which is a lot easier when you're not buying whiskey slash rounds in Brooklyn.
Baas um,
and he further goes on to say,
so thanks for setting a good example on how to keep that shit in check.
Only problem is is it's kind of messing up my game or what I thought was my
game,
which might've just been getting drunk enough to think of a six was a nine for
the night instead of practicing some patients and self control.
Did you do the 100 days when you were with Nia or did you do even,
did you ever do sober stints?
Single?
I'm a single dude in my thirties and I'm a writer so I don't have an automatic
social life unless I go out at night.
Basically that means up till now I've met all my previous girlfriends at bars or
at shows.
But now I feel like if I'm sober and they're not,
then isn't that kind of like taking advantage?
I know exactly what you're saying.
Yeah.
A lack of a Gal's got two plus drinks in her and I'm not in the same rocking
boat.
I'm just standing on the deck watching everyone else swaying back and forth.
It almost seems shady DB picking up gals.
In other words,
how the hell do you meet cool chicks?
If you're taking a gentleman interlude from the booze.
I know in the past you've recommended like mixed gendered sports and stuff.
Just wondering if,
uh,
you got any other insights.
Thanks and go,
uh,
not even gonna say it.
Um,
all right,
so judging by that you're not athletic because you already know what I
suggested.
So I would,
I would get involved in something else.
Get involved in some of Dude,
if you could somehow cut out booze and bars out of your fucking life at some
point.
It's a great thing.
Get eight hours sleep,
you get more shit done and then you start doing,
uh,
you know,
something else.
I don't know what,
join a fucking gym.
Join in,
but join like a specific one.
Like,
you know,
they got like those rock climbing gyms.
It's way more social because it's like a specific thing that everybody's into.
If you just go to the treadmill,
elliptical weight thing,
you know,
then everybody's got their fucking headphones on and shit.
But um,
you know,
if it's something more like a,
like that rock climbing stuff for,
uh,
I dunno,
riding a bike,
my shit's always physically active.
I don't know what else to do.
I mean,
I don't know what other types of interaction things,
you know,
what the fuck he supposed to do,
but I respect the fact that you don't like hitting on a woman when she's drunk
and you're sober.
Yeah,
I don't like that either.
That feels like some form of sexual assault.
If you end up hooking up with them,
you know,
if they're all over you,
you out.
And I was still was always like,
all right,
well,
you know,
let me know what you think tomorrow.
You know,
after the fucking a hang over there.
All right,
there boozy.
Um,
I should fucking take a day off man.
I fucking drank it up yesterday,
last night,
ended up eating off of food truck,
got a super fucking deluxe Burrito,
whatever the hell you call it.
Horrific.
And I'm paying for it today.
All God Damn Day.
No energy.
If stupid fucking stupid,
why can't I stop?
Maybe I should join that rock climbing gym.
All right.
stamps.com everybody.
You know that feeling you get when you get things done with just the click of
your mouse,
it can't get more convenient than that.
You know what?
I have a mouse in my house at eight might my bananas the other day.
I couldn't kill it though.
If I found it,
I'd try to catch it by the tail and then throw it outside through little
helicopter thing.
Make it dizzy so wouldn't know how to get back at my house anyways and now you
can get your mailing and shipping done without leaving your desk.
Thanks to stamps.com stamps.com turns your PC or your Mac or your own personal
post office that never does or that never closes.
It's sorry.
I look at words and then I move on to the next sentence.
I really should just stay on the war on the words here.
Talk about convenient buy and print official us postage for any letter or
package using your computer and your printer just and then just hand your mail
to the mail man or mail lady or drop it off in the post office box and all the
mailbox.
Sorry.
And you'll never have to go to the post office again.
I use stamps.com to send out my posters or whatever other thing I'm selling at
the end of my show.
I am a moron if I can figure out how to use the Goddamn scale.
So can you right now use my last name bur bur for this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer.
Offer awful offer that includes a digital scale,
calculates exact postage for letters and packages and up to 55 bucks free
postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburpeeyouarearethatstamps.com enter burr.
And lastly,
but certainly not leastly prosper or is everybody likes to say it [inaudible] is
72 hours.
You could have $35,000 to cover your needs.
What will you do?
Pay Off a high rate credit card.
Start a business,
do that home improvement project.
Um,
you know what I would do?
I would get an exterminator.
The best one ever for 35 grand to take out that mouse that's eaten my bananas.
Um,
anyways,
with our sponsor prosper,
it's never been easier.
Go Online,
answer a few questions and see how low fixed rate.
See your low fixed rate and seconds.
Your money hits your account in as few as three days.
Prosper.
The fastest growing peer to peer lender and they facilitated over $1 billion in
loans to peekaboo.
People like you.
They're revolutionary platform connects people looking to borrow money with
those who have money to invest.
There's no outrageous fees,
no raising interest rates,
and you'll never have to set foot in a bank again.
Just go to proffer.com/bur bur to check out your rate instantly without
affecting your credit score.
For a limited time prosper is offering my listeners a $50 visa prepaid gift
card.
When you get alone,
go to prosper.com/for up to $35,000 in just three days in a $50 gift card.
Go to prosper.com/burr mandatory legal disclaimer,
everybody other restrictions apply.
See Site for details.
Gift Card is issued by Center State Bank of Florida pursuant to license from
Visa USA incorporated.
All personal loans are made by Web Bank,
uh,
Utah Chartered Industrial Bank member,
FDIC equal housing lender.
All right,
and there you go.
There's the ads for this week.
Um,
okay.
Here we go.
Here's another guy laying off the booze and another guy laying off the booze.
Billy buster of balls.
I'm a big fan and an even bigger booze hound.
I'm a 47 year old boozer with a good job successfully raising my two young
daughters myself.
You recently went on a run of sobriety that I admire.
Can you talk more on your fucking epic podcast?
Thank you.
About how you did it and what types of foods you ate to help you replace the
sugar that your body mist without the sweet mother's milk of vodka.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Yeah,
dude,
you're addicted.
You're addicted to sugar.
Like most people like myself or whatever.
So,
um,
what I found with food is it's really all about that first night,
you know,
if he can eat well all day on the first day you diet and right around four
o'clock,
five o'clock in the afternoon,
you're body starts craving the shit food that you've been eating.
Either something salty or sugary or anything.
If he can just fucking push through that,
you know,
drink plenty of water,
not a dangerous level of water.
Don't fucking make the walls of yourselves fucking not even exist anymore.
Is that what happens when you can lean in,
literally die from drinking too much water?
Just drink water,
big salad with a protein and then just make yourself go to bed,
that white knuckle it the first night and then your body starts to get used to
that.
And after doing that for three days,
you on a nice track and
okay
to help you along if you get that.
Um,
Hey Nia,
what is it?
Dark chocolate.
Yeah.
If you get that dark chocolate,
um,
it's weird.
Like,
he just seemed like a little corner of it.
It feels way more dense than like milk chocolate,
but it's not nearly as sugary.
I don't even know if there's any sugar in it,
but it kind of keeps that sugar thing at bay.
And that's kind of a way you can kind of cheat your way through it.
But what's cool about your bodies if you actually feed it healthy food,
it craves healthy food.
Like you'll actually get psyched for a salad with some chicken on it or some
shit.
Believe it or not.
I never thought it was gonna be possible.
But I would say,
you know,
you've gotta be careful with the,
obviously with the salad dressings,
you know,
um,
and people always say when they talk about calories and shit,
the low,
say like,
you might as well have had a big Mac.
I 100% disagree with that.
Um,
it might,
even if the kid caloric intake is equal,
there's nothing worse than a fucking big Mac because at the end of the day,
if you had a giant fucking salad with a ton of calorie dressing on top of it,
you still ate a fucking salad.
Where have a big Mac.
You just ate a big Mac.
All right.
And fuck all,
you know,
net con personal trainers who are now going to question that.
I that makes sense to me.
And I don't give a shit about your degree and fucking salad dressing.
Um,
yeah,
so just white knuckle it for the first three.
I need to do that.
Like I'm trying to get back into working out.
I've been so fucking busy and I'm forcing myself to go downstairs
cause my body is saying I don't want to do it.
I don't want to do it.
You drank last night,
he ate that shit food,
let's fucking relax and eat more shit food.
And I'm just going to force myself to go down there and all I gotta do is that
first set of pushups.
The blood gets going and then the body's like,
yeah,
I want to do this,
I want to do this.
And then,
you know,
half hour later like thank God I did this and it's fucking over.
So,
uh,
another great thing,
especially a guy your age,
your almost your little a year older than me,
take a fucking walk at night a take a fucking walk.
I'm telling you,
just walk around the block at a nice leisurely pace,
you know,
put it on your Walkman or whatever the fuck he listened to.
Now,
whatever the hell you call it,
your phone,
your transistor radio,
listen to some music,
walk around the block.
Um,
yeah,
it's great.
You're burned cat little calories.
You're not beating on your joints.
You know your burn like a hundred,
200 calories just walking around the block right before he go to bed.
Nice big glass of fucking water.
Go to bed and then start your day.
I'd like fucking oatmeal with bananas and raising in it.
No milk,
no brown sugar,
none of that shit that's going to send your body back,
get you back on this smack.
Fuck that big lump of shit that's good for you.
Sits right in your belly.
It fills you up.
Have a fucking apple for a snack and then,
I don't know,
peanut butter and jelly sandwich or a Turkey sandwich,
lean Turkey sandwich and you're on your way,
and then you're all the way to four o'clock.
Then I got to do,
it's a salad and the protein and just shoved that shit.
Sometimes I'll do the salad at lunch just to get it out of the fucking way.
He's got to get it all away.
Just fucking do that.
And it's the end of the night.
Again,
drink a giant thing of water.
Take another fucking walk,
and then your body's just enter that and then you'll drop weight.
And then the hardest fucking thing is once your body gets used to that and you
get bored of that Shit,
Oh,
you start lying to yourself like,
hey,
I could have a big Mac.
I've been doing,
I've been,
now,
you know,
I'm gonna treat myself.
I've been doing well and you're basically,
I've tried,
you're treating yourself to the heroin again and it's going to be in you for
three days and you've gotta be really careful after you eat like shit for the
next three days because there's that demon is back in.
You go and get,
get a pizza that get some ice cream,
but blah,
blah,
blah.
I'm telling you that at least that's how my body works.
Um,
anyway,
so good luck man.
You're making some smart choices there.
Alright,
threesome problems.
Oh God.
I want this guy's life is fucking great threesome.
Hey Nia,
you want to come in for this one?
Neato
while you were all stuffy.
Come on.
That'll be funny.
Next week.
Okay.
All right,
three some problems.
Greetings Billy boy,
longtime listener,
first time caller question mark.
As they used to say,
I realize many,
if not most guys would love to have my problems,
but nonetheless,
it's caused me some headaches.
So I thought I'd ask an asshole like you for his 2 cents.
Well,
you've come to the right place if you're looking for an a hole.
My wife of years.
It's very much by sexual and we have brought other women into our relationship
since we started dating.
All right,
so,
okay.
Yeah.
Is that still technically a marriage?
I'm not trying to be approved here but like um,
okay.
All right,
so you guys are like friends.
It's fucking great.
This is great.
This fucking guy.
How the fuck did you pull this off?
Nah,
not like we,
I guess cause his wife's bisexual anyways.
Not like we do this every Friday night but since we are both very sexual people
and the fact that she has no interest in screwing another dude,
it's just a win win.
Yeah.
You mother fucker.
What it,
what,
what is your problem?
He,
you taken up valuable time on this podcast for other people actually have
problems.
It goes here is the rub,
the so to speak.
Nudge,
nudge,
wink,
wink.
Most of the girls have been hookups more or less and that neither of us had any
real emotional attachment to them.
Yeah,
you got it.
I would think you'd have to do it that way.
What are you going to bang your neighbor and then have to see her for the rest
of the time you lay aria at the time.
Like Dental Joe.
Then my wife was doing that other thing too.
You know,
we don't want to do it again.
We just wanted to do it.
Do you want
have a nice day?
I for a while.
That sounds crass.
All three,
sometimes even four.
One,
five,
five at once.
All of us were consulting adults,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
How did you have a,
a two,
one five.
Okay.
Did you go?
You must,
you guys must be swingers.
Where'd you go down to the why we got,
we got next.
We've got next
standing outside an orgy.
Um,
anyways,
he said,
but there is one good friend of my wife that is found her way into our bed off
and on for a few years now.
Usually after all of us have had one too many cocktails.
Yeah,
Dude.
All right.
Yeah,
you're dancing with the devil here again.
So far so good.
Except that this lady,
let's call her Jenny Jannie.
I got your number.
You want to Bang my wife?
Um,
okay.
So far so good.
It's just,
okay.
We'll call her.
Jenny is just as into each of us personally as she is into us as a couple.
That is,
she is down to screw each one of us individually.
Now this person right here is the real winner in all of this because you know
she's not in a relationship this first.
She's the one getting her cake and eating it.
She has nothing to fucking loose.
Um,
anyways,
she says,
well,
my wife was away on business.
Ah,
I gave in and did the Dade.
Jenny insists that a,
my wife would not consider this cheating and B,
even if she did she that is Jenny would never tell her.
Part of the problem is that,
like I mentioned,
my wife has zero interest in other dudes and being the ex Frat guy that I am,
I really would not be jealous if she informed me that she slept with a girl
while on a business trip.
But at the same time,
my gut is telling me she'd be very angry and very hurt if she learned that I
slept with Jenny.
One or one on one in our absence.
Jenny,
I have had sex three times in my wife's absence.
Yeah,
dude,
you're kind of having an affair right now.
I feel like I am about the absolute limit at which I can admit all to my wife.
That is after four,
five,
six,
eight,
12,
whatever times it is no longer a new problem and it's simply an affair.
Should I just come clean now considering that this is not exactly your run of
the mill affair.
Thanks my man.
Um,
I dunno dude.
I would,
I would immediately stop banging Jenny on the side.
Um,
you know what dude,
you're relationship is a complex to say the least and uh,
there's going to be some security issues.
There's going to be some breaches in security.
So you had a breach in security.
She's not going to say anything.
You don't say anything.
You know,
you basically fuck this woman that your wife has fucked.
She just wasn't there.
So I don't know what that is.
Uh,
that sounds like a a,
that sounds like offsetting penalties.
No,
not really.
Cause you cause your wife is the other team.
Um,
I dunno for,
I,
I would,
I would stop banging her and you did it three fucking times.
I Dunno if you want to say that.
That's your call.
If you want to say something,
say something.
You know that's going to be a shitstorm and your wife is probably going to think
you know there are vengeful,
uh,
sex.
So do the math on that one.
If she's going to get you back.
I don't think she's getting with Jenny.
She's getting with Lenny.
Oh sorry.
Apologize.
Apologize for the Pun.
Arm.
Is that upon?
I don't know what it is.
Um,
so there you go.
That is the,
uh,
that's the podcast for this week.
Everybody,
uh,
j e t s Jess jets,
jets tonight playing.
I don't know who,
I don't know what,
I haven't watched him yet this year,
but I am predicting the New England patriots are going to go 500 against the
jets,
500 against the bills,
500 against the dolphins.
Maybe we'll be one of them twice.
Um,
I think all three of them might've got a little better.
And I just think that we get a little worse.
I Dunno.
I just a,
there's just something about it.
I don't know,
letting the Raiders hang around that long.
The Raiders,
no disrespect to the greatest fucking emblem and all sports,
but they are what they are and have been what they've been for this fucking
long.
So I don't know what to tell you.
Um,
anyways,
other than I'm looking forward to it.
I'm trying not to be a cunt this year and a rooting against teams and all that
shit.
It really kills a lot of my enjoyment of it.
I know it's funny for you guys in that type of shit,
but I'm just really busy.
I don't know.
I don't have time to fucking hate this year.
Uh,
that's it.
I'm just hoping it's going to be a good game.
How do you like that?
That was even handed.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.